who does the arctic belong to the vast
region was long seen as little more than
snow
and ice but now three world powers
russia china and the united states are
leading the charge to take control of
the immense natural resources
and new trade routes that are opening up
even as a potential climate catastrophe
takes hold so on to the point we ask
polar power play who win the race for
the arctic's
riches
[Music]
well thanks very much for joining us
here on to the point where my guests are
michael powell a specialist on security
issues and the arctic in particular
with the german institute for
international and security affairs
his opinion in light of the competing
security interests of russia
china and america we urgently need a
military
dialogue also with us is the
oceanographer and climatologist stefan
ramsdall from the potsdam institute
for climate impact research he argues
that things that happen in the arctic
don't necessarily stay
in the arctic and a very warm welcome to
to irena
philatova from dw's russia desk in bonn
who says the arctic has vast economic
resources
and russia wants a big slice of the
cake well thank you all free for being
with me today interesting insights to
begin the show and to get us going i'd
like to begin by asking michelle powell
the apparently uh straightforward
question
who does the arctic belong to
oh it's quite clear the area around the
north pole belongs to
human mankind and the rest is clearly
defined by
international law a law of the sea and
yeah russia claimed in 2007
that the arctic is russia that yeah
okay a straightforward answer based on
principles of law you say
why are things so tense around the
region at this point in time
well in former times it was called high
north and low tension
but right now in the uh years after 2007
when
president putin claimed russia's return
as a world power
they started also re-military
militarization in the arctic
reactivating former bases from the cold
war times
and so on okay stephan runsdorf you are
the scientist in our ranks and i'd like
to ask you the same question who does
the arctic belong to
because i anticipate we might get a
different answer well i think that the
the whole arctic ocean should be
declared as a common heritage of
humanity
and the nations should pull together to
protect the arctic is that likely to
happen
um it's it's happened in antarctica
so it's not out of the question and we
are in an unprecedented climate crisis
the arctic is warming three times faster
than the whole globe
the ice is melting away and this is
affecting all nations
through sea level rise from melting
greenland ice through the effects on the
jet stream and our weather systems
in the mid latitudes for example okay
let's bring in irina fellatova from bonn
irina why is the region suddenly so
important everybody's talking about it
much more than they were
what's brought this together to sort of
create the interest
well i wouldn't say that it suddenly got
so important
the interest in the arctic has been
there for decades
it's just that like michael powell
already said
russia declared its return to the arctic
2007
and clearly there
has come more realization from other
countries uh about the strategic
importance of this region
and of course also arctic got into the
spotlight
um in connection with uh the estimates
um
uh of scientific estimates it's about
the
uh enormous potential resources that are
hidden in the arctic and of course um
like we said in the introduction
everybody wants wants a big slice of pie
this is why uh the countries have
intensified
the arctic countries have intensified
their uh activities in the arctic have
started to show more ambition but not
even them i mean look at china
they also have declared themselves a
near-arctic country although they don't
even have a direct access to the arctic
ocean
um what does the arctic mean to ordinary
russians
i'm sorry what does the arctic mean to
ordinary russians you're talking a lot
about sort of
you know resources and history and what
have you but what about you know the
russian soul
well i need to say that russians are
very proud of
the arctic uh there are many examples of
that
for example arctic has become a
huge part of the russian cultural legacy
there are
a lot of um books written about it a lot
of
fairy tales a lot of films have been
made in russia but
the arctic exploration there is also one
fun fact
actually there is in moscow special
house
which is called the house of polar
researchers the house of arctic
researchers it was it is also actually
part of their
um architectural legacy in russia it's a
historical it's a memorial right now but
the house was built in the 1930s
um for the arctic researchers and their
families
and uh it's still functioning as a
residential house i mean people live
there still yeah
it's even possible to buy apartments
over there but back then in the 30s i
mean
it was actually um decorated and built
uh like in a very fancy way i mean to
provide as
more comfort for the people who work in
the arctic as possible kind of
compensate for the severe conditions
they have to work in
um let me just cut in because i think i
i i can sense your passion and i can
understand the message it's all about
prestige and i could hear you michelle
sort of nodding in the background yeah
that the
prestige and a kind of it's reminiscent
a little bit of the sort of
the cold war you know space race almost
yeah it's i just wanted to add that
there are also the darker sides of the
arctic of the russian arctic
which began in terrorist times with the
prisoner camps and ended with alexander
schwarzenez
gulag so that's the dark side of the
arctic
and uh clearly it became a hot spot now
uh because of uh interests of
in in the context of great power rivalry
that means that uh yeah china has
declared itself a new arctic state
and everybody was a little bit surprised
because geographically it makes no
sense okay we'll talk about that just in
just a second the
the chinese the russians and the
americans sort of a three-way race for
a power grab essentially stefan you said
something at the beginning of the show
that i thought was very interesting
things that happened in the arctic don't
necessarily stay in the arctic
what do you mean well the arctic
is is a very vulnerable ecosystem and
vulnerable region and one of the key
factors in terms of
climate is that it reflects a lot of
sunlight by the bright ice and snow
surfaces
and as these shrink the global warming
is amplified
and even just shipping activities in the
arctic
make the eyes shrink faster because
there are suit emissions which settle on
the
bright snow and ice surfaces make them
darker and that
helps to heat up the globe and then when
the green and ice sheet melts
there is a tipping point there which you
know could be
reached even below two degrees of
warming which will mean that
eventually it will take a long time but
we will get about seven meters of global
sea level rise
if we push greenland past that tipping
point and then obviously the coast
worldwide will be massively impacted by
that okay
let's just get some images that will
give us a feel for what is at stake in
the
rivalry that we've already touched on
and the environmental factors that
stefan has been speaking about
the arctic is warming more quickly than
any other place on earth
from the 7.6 million square kilometers
of ice that were there 40 years ago
only half that amount remains in the
next decade
there could be no ice there during the
summertime
that would make raw materials like oil
and gas more accessible
as well as rare earths and precious
metals it would be a billion dollar
treasure industry
five countries within the arctic circle
each have a 370 kilometer wide zone
the usa canada denmark norway
and russia
but a huge area around the north pole
doesn't belong to any of them
so far russia has laid the strongest
claim to it
but china also has strong ambitions and
the country has already secured rare
earths in greenland
china now sees itself as a near-arctic
state because of the northeast passage
which has eased maritime travel and
shortened distances
china's goal is a polar silk road
exploiting the arctic at what price
stefan let's come back to that question
exploiting the outtake at what price
exactly give us a
more of a picture of that well i have
mentioned sea level rise
there's also the gulf stream system
which has a
huge influence on the climate not only
around the north atlantic
even down to the tropics and we have
recently
uh published a study with much stronger
evidence that this system is already
slowing
partly due to melt water from greenland
diluting the oceans in the north
and there's also growing evidence that
the
disproportionate warming of the arctic
is affecting the jet stream
and it makes the polar vortex more
unstable so this exceptional cold air
outbreaks into north america into europe
in this january and february have to do
with the extreme warming of the arctic
and so even our weather in the united
states in europe is affected by these
changes going on in the arctic
it's interesting i found a quote from
you yourself you say to continue
trying to dig up fossil fuels is absurd
and you appear to be
saying not just we're not just digging
out resources but we're digging our own
graves it's pretty drastic
well yes all nations have agreed in the
paris agreement to limit global warming
to well below
2 degrees if possible 1.5 degrees and
that means
we have a limited amount of fossil fuels
we can still burn and the known reserves
are already about three times larger so
we have a lot of fossil fuel reserves
that are just
unburnable carbon as it's the technical
term is
and so it's stupid to spend a lot of
money to look for more
and in highly vulnerable risky places
like the arctic
that's especially stupid okay so that
you might say is the
is the is the price p-r-i-c-e
arena meanwhile there is a prize here
p-r-i-z-e
because the i mean we're looking at
incredible resources here politic
uh oil gas precious metals gold uranium
and so on
uh who's gonna press who's going to
profit most
well uh the one who is the first is
going to profit most
of course um because we know that there
are huge resources i mean
they're not proven yet but they're
suggested there are huge resources in
the arctic
and uh russia for example already is
trying to claim its right for
more uh parts of the offshore uh for
example the la manos of ridge
um it already applied with the united
nations
um and the minos of ridge is actually
the part of the shelf
where actually huge uh reserves of the
um raw materials are supposed to be
and if russia managed to get approval
from the united states from the united
nations and if um
actually um there is a confirmation that
russia can claim these parts of the
shelter themselves
then russia will be able to develop this
potential oil and gas field another
question is
whether it's economically viable for
russia to do so it's very difficult i
mean imagine you have to work in the
severe arctic condition
in a very sensitive environment it's uh
a lot of money really does russia have
it
not necessarily because we're in the
pandemic i mean we see that the russian
economy is actually not doing so well
recently
and also the question of technology
matters uh russia does not necessarily
have enough technology to go forward
with all these projects
and we can see for example the um
stockman project in the uh
in the arctic uh it's a project to
develop condom
to extract condensate gas it
uh has been put on ice for the next few
years because russia acknowledges they
don't have enough technology to go
forward with it
so it's a huge question i mean uh no
matter
that russia is where it wants to go but
it's not quite sure how it's going to
get there you could say
michelle i just like to come back to the
the the point that we were talking about
about uh
the the colonial legacy almost or the
colonial
feel to all this you know we talk a lot
about the race
about a charge about a push about a
power play and about
plunder and about countries winning
their booty
it's all very reminiscent of the
colonial period the colonial legacy tell
us a little bit more about that
with respect to greenland for example uh
clearly the colonial legacy
is still existing and reminds
greenlanders that they have to
say they have still to to work for
independence by
for example exploiting rare earth
and that's one of the issues
the whole debate on the arctic goes
about
because that was the interest clearly
the chinese people had in greenland
and that was also attractive to uh u.s
president
donald trump you remember uh who wanted
to buy
greenland because of rare earth and
because of the
geostrategic importance of greenland
clearly
there are very many aspects stefan
one really interesting thing about this
story about the future of the arctic is
that it brings together
military issues geopolitical issues
economic issues and environmental issues
i know you're a person of ideas can you
somehow weave that all together to sort
of
explain how those the interdependence of
those factors
well this is a tough question and but i
i would say what's going on now
with with the race for resources in the
arctic
and and economic benefits is
very much a kind of 20th century thing
and we're now in the 21st century we're
in a climate crisis
which threatens civilization as we know
it
and we all live together on this one
fragile planet and
we shouldn't be working against each
other especially not in the arctic but
also not anywhere else we we need to
work together
to solve this crisis okay uh
the arctic once a demilitarized zone is
now rapidly being militarized
in essence as we've already seen it's a
freeway race for power and
influence for the first time the u s air
force is deploying b-1 bombers to norway
just a few weeks after his inauguration
president biden is sending a message to
russia the usa is prepared to defend its
allies against potential russian
aggression
experts see it as a signal that the u.s
doesn't want to lose its claim to the
arctic
the race for new economic opportunities
in the arctic has brought with it
militarization
the kremlin says russia has been arming
itself in the north for years
by building army bases to defend its
territory and legitimate interests
s-400 missiles can reach greenland or
alaska
nato responded to the maneuver with
large-scale military exercises like the
trident juncture war games in norway in
2018
for decades the arctic was regarded as a
conflict-free zone
how dangerous is this armament
there's a tendency to blame the russians
for the militarization of the arctic is
that fair
well um i mean you have to say that way
russia has been seen and still is seen
by many countries in the world also by
their but its neighbor countries as
an aggressor uh we can see the baltic
state look at the baltic states
uh they are very much concerned about
potential
russian aggression so um it's clear that
the countries have some concerns so to
say about
uh russia's expanding military presence
in russia so
um and they're not wrong vladimir putin
would surely come in now and say the
russia's coastline makes 53
of the arctic ocean there are two
million russians living in the arctic
region
he would say it's it's good and right
that russia is the top
dog the us that russia is the most
important nation in the region
well um russia is not the most important
nation in the region first of all let's
say that way most of the
resources which are proven in the arctic
they
actually already they are located in the
russian part of the shelf
it's clear it's over 90 percent so we
don't argue with that
but uh if we say see from the point of
view who arctic belongs to
i mean of course there is the
international legislation which
regulates the issue the u.n convention
on the law of the sea which says that
every country
only has the first 200c miles
for itself and not more and if you want
more you have to go through a long
procedure
so uh basically russia is tied by the
international legislation just exactly
like all other countries
okay michelle powell china for its part
we mentioned it already
has called it has decided to call itself
a near arctic state what should we
understand there what is a
what are the chinese ambitions and how
threatening may they be
for some clearly chinese interests and
ambitions are far-reaching
and when you when you cause a
when you kill the polar silk road
as part of the bard and road initiative
you have
the term pola so it's not only the
arctic but it's also the antarctic so
you have a global ambition
with that respect and further on
we are we are the interests of china in
greenland for example are well known
china already now is the world
leader in the production of rare earth
elements so it's really the dominant
player and wants even to
to extend that uh that dominant
status so there are very many aspects
concerning china especially in its
cooperation with russia
and that's in the field of naval
cooperation
clearly something people are concerned
about
stefan if you were if you had the
opportunity
to be a german representative in a
meeting with
vladimir putin to talk about uh the
future of the region
what would you ask for what would you
recommend
well i i would probably say that
we we need a new era of global
cooperation
and after the u.s elections there's more
hope for that
because we are facing a common enemy and
that is global heating
are you uh there's a there's a new man
in the white house obviously joe biden
are you
as a climatologist are you encouraged by
his present presence
in in the white house because he's also
you know when it comes to the article
he's been he's been relatively
belligerent it's not the word but he's
been very gung-ho so far
well in terms of climate change i'm very
encouraged
because i i know john kerry for example
personally who is a very good
climate diplomat very passionate about
the topic
and he he got the right advisors now
some of my
really excellent climate science
colleagues from the usa
advising the presidency and uh i think
i think he has said something like the
united states is back leading on the
climate issue i don't think they ever
have
but i think they are now gearing up to
be a leader on the climate issue
um who's got who's going to be the lead
there are tensions there are at least
three well just one question there are
smaller nations involved as well and you
were taught before we came on air
you were talking michelle about your
concerns about uh sweden for example
to share a little bit of that for with
us well sweden just has
written in its uh most recent arctic
strategy
that there are a military dynamic which
they are concerned about and
that's clearly a concern also the other
scandinavian
countries share like norway
there's an organization called the
arctic council we need to mention them
sort of explain who they are and what
they're you know what would
you hope from oh the chair will go from
iceland to russia in may
of this year so we will have russia uh
chairing the arctic council for the next
two years and i'm
yeah hopefully there will be a meeting
not only of the
foreign ministers but also with john
kerry
in reykjavik in may so they could
exchange views about
the future of the arctic irina are you
optimistic from a russian perspective
about uh about possible talks between
the players
uh in terms of creating a more
rules-based future for the region
well i hope so uh at least when it comes
to
uh the climate change issue because
there was kind of
a wake-up call wake-up call for russia
last year in
uh in the summer of last year uh when
there was a huge
uh diesel spill from the facilities of
norris nicole they're
russia's biggest nickel producer in
siberia and
a lot of fuel got into siberian rivers
and these russia doesn't want to speak
about that openly apparently but this
happened because of the throwing
permafrost
because this reservoir where the fuel
was contained it was standing on the
permafrost
so this is kind of a wake-up call for
russia i hope they now will turn
their eyes a bit more to the climate
changes and we'll talk about that more
will be ready to cooperate in this
direction more
you optimistic that the americans can
influence the russians in this way that
they can
seek dialogue and create dialogue well i
make no political judgment
as a natural scientist
michelle you said at the beginning of
the show we need
military dialogue and we need it
urgently
that's going to give me sleepless nights
why do we need military dialogue
urgently
because russia and the americans should
talk about
military issues in the arctic and
uh the experts are quite
quite agree about that point uh in both
moscow and washington that there should
be a dialogue as soon as possible
okay last question on the show the
question i asked at the beginning who'll
win the race for the arctic's britches
stefan rumsdorf well i hope
we all together will win and it
shouldn't be a race against each other
michelle yeah i'm an optimist too an
optimist too and the arena in
uh in in bond from the russian dw's
russia desk in bonn
who is going to win the race for the
arctic's riches
well it's not about who's going to win
the race it's about uh
that we don't destroy the sensitive
environment i would say and
there has to be a common responsibility
of all the countries involved
thank you all three for being with us
today we've been discussing the future
of the arctic i hope things
develop well and peacefully in the
future if you've enjoyed the show as
much as i have and we've given you some
food for thought do come back next time
around until then
bye bye and choose
[Music]
[Music]
you